>> Hello, everyone. I'm Sumit Chandel, and
I will talk to you guys about Ad Parameters
in v2009. It should be a pretty short undertaking.
I just want to introduce you guys [INDISTINCT]
in case if you're not aware of it yet. So,
this [INDISTINCT] we'll go through explaining
what they are and why they're useful, looking
at an example, looking at some codes, some
pretty--pretty simple to use and you'll see,
and then go to Q&A to see whether [INDISTINCT].
And, of course, throughout, I'm going to [INDISTINCT]
you know. All right. So Ad Parameters, what
they are? It let's you change numerical values
in your AdWords, okay? So, that has some advantages;
one is--if you had an ad that's performing
really well, and let's say, you--you could
change the values from--for example, you're
selling skis for $200, your ad hasn't [INDISTINCT]
and it's really doing well and [INDISTINCT],
let's say you're a businessman [INDISTINCT]
and says, "Hey [INDISTINCT] we're going to
get good luck [INDISTINCT]." So you could
do that and [INDISTINCT] but you have to have
to create a new ad to modify the existing
one, and the disadvantage of that is you lose
the history of its existence on the ad and
how it is performing. All right, so those
kind things when they'll [INDISTINCT] ask
in why we're introducing Ad Parameters. So,
with Ad Parameters, you can change those numeric
values without having to change the rest of
the ad and you can keep all the history and
the steps. And for the other advantage, it
let's you keep your [INDISTINCT] targeted
to your customers [INDISTINCT] specific information
about [INDISTINCT]. Okay, so let's [INDISTINCT],
so here's an ad, [INDISTINCT] would give us
amazing deals on brand new skis, let's say,
this gets to [INDISTINCT]. All right, so it's
not too bad, it is the right season for the
ad, so that's a plus. But there is a problem
with this ad, and the problem should not be
asked because that sucks, right? Well, why
does it suck? So same [INDISTINCT] but which
brand exactly, okay? Say--say it how much
am I going to save? What's the percentage?
What's the [INDISTINCT]? So as a user, if
I saw it, I would much less likely [INDISTINCT]
buy it, compared to an ad that had all the
information there. So, I know exactly what
I'm getting once I put it on. So, here's another
ad and [INDISTINCT] over that. So there's
no [INDISTINCT] brand names, so let's [INDISTINCT],
I know that. And save 20% on the [INDISTINCT]
prices, so this one is a bit better, all right.
You still have to [INDISTINCT] and that is
the fact that, if these are team, this ad
once you [INDISTINCT] change it, if they want
they want to change a certain percentages
for whatnot, that would be a new ad [INDISTINCT].
So here is an ad with Ad Parameters and this
is most [INDISTINCT]. And so I just here [INDISTINCT]
save Param1 big time. So Param1 [INDISTINCT]
that's the Ad Parameter, that's the only one
you can insert various values, various numeric
values with all that changes, and that would
change the rest of the. The thing of [INDISTINCT]
in mix with Param1, that's the default text.
So [INDISTINCT] you don't have a map [INDISTINCT]
on it, then it will jus show that type of
setting. So, that's where you can put default
text feature, like I was aiming for [INDISTINCT]
and numerical values only. So, default text
can be [INDISTINCT]. The table below that
shows on which keyword for setting the AdWord,
so that's an important point about how Ad
Parameters work, they need to be set on the
keywords. So, they're not set on the ad but
it's the keyword that triggers it. So if I
would say that this Ad Parameter on the keyword
[INDISTINCT], that 20% will be placed under
[INDISTINCT]. So, numerical values and [INDISTINCT]
values are supported, percentage values actually
aren't [INDISTINCT]. As I was designing this
example [INDISTINCT], it seemed natural to
me to put a percentage in that, and I was
told later that it's not actually not supported
and [INDISTINCT] heard of that, and of course,
that's [INDISTINCT] that someone ask this
question about what about percentages, we
consider it [INDISTINCT] reason why we shouldn't
have this. So this will probably make a [INDISTINCT]
2009 sometimes because it makes sense [INDISTINCT].
Okay, great. So, as I was saying, this is
a much better Ad [INDISTINCT] parameters right
there. So, let's see this in code just to
see if it works. So, it's really, really simple
to do this, this is just like in the Java
[INDISTINCT] and yet a very [INDISTINCT] example.
So just create AdWord's user [INDISTINCT]
Ad Parameter's service interface [INDISTINCT]
used to. Here you just pass the--I'll point
out [INDISTINCT] the AdGroup and the [INDISTINCT].
Then, finally, here the Ad Parameter. So,
you said the [INDISTINCT] around the new search
and text. One of the [INDISTINCT] here is
the Param index is one. So Ad Parameters are
one index rather zero index. I'm not sure
why exactly [INDISTINCT]. It's just something
to note. You set the operator, another important
point here. The operator is always set as
opposed to add, even if this is a new Ad Parameter.
So that's just the way Ad Parameters work,
you never use ad for a new one or an updated
[INDISTINCT], you will never use it. And then
here, you just click the Ad Param1 operation
[INDISTINCT] here and [INDISTINCT], get the
results--get the result back, the Ad Params
are in, and then basically just check it out
as [INDISTINCT]. Do you have questions about
that? Okay, so back right now, so, you know,
this is much better, right? But it's still
not perfect. There can be more improvements
for this. So as I was saying the Ad Params
are set at the [INDISTINCT] level, so if you
want to [INDISTINCT] is the most effective
way possible. You should try then to [INDISTINCT]
keywords [INDISTINCT]. So in this case, I
know I have another parameter that I have
in there [INDISTINCT] starting at param1 at
low prices [INDISTINCT]. So, those are the
info that I have in there and in the bottom
[INDISTINCT] if someone pick up this ad [INDISTINCT].
So that's what makes it more powerful and,
of course, it [INDISTINCT] I can keep the
specifics, change its [INDISTINCT]. Okay,
so Ad Parameters, just some good things to
know when you're using them. A few things
have already been mentioned; the first is
that they're set on keywords and not on ads.
So, again, that might [INDISTINCT] but once
you'll get used to it [INDISTINCT]. The whole
numerical values [INDISTINCT] values except
for the default text, the one [INDISTINCT]
and that's because if you look at the [INDISTINCT]
it wouldn't actually makes sense how you changed
the Ad Parameter value of that, so [INDISTINCT]
and it's just the way it's design [INDISTINCT].
And [INDISTINCT] that will go hand in hand.